you're saying that more genius civil
servants said to you I'm finding working
for Mr Rob really difficult there's this
has happened all that's happened please
can you talk to him about it but don't
mention me and you try to relay that
and he didn't accept that that's correct
okay were you surprised that he didn't
accept that or dismayed oh
dismayed because
I think that
he was in control of his behaviors I
think he could have changed his
behaviors and he chose not to change his
behavior what were the behaviors well as
he himself has described I think that
Adam tolley's report lays out Dominic
Robb in a fair and accurate way when you
read the report did you sing Oh maybe I
should have done more
um given what happened in my year with
him uh you know I feel uneasy but I
still understand what I did let me put
another way do you think he should
apologize for his behavior now yes you
do and were you just made that he didn't
yes
um the former head of the Civil Service
law cars Lake uh warned today that the
Prime Minister needs to speak out
against the torrent of invective against
the Civil Service
I agree I think the Prime Minister who
is also the minister for the Civil
Service uh he knows the Civil Service he
is surrounded by civil servants in
number 10 and the cabinet office he
knows their ethos he knows their quality
so I hope that the Prime Minister and
other ministers do publicly recognize
that what I saw in his acceptance letter
of Mr Robb was immense sympathy with Mr
Robb as Mr Robb railed against the Civil
Service I think I would distinguish
sharply if I were the Prime Minister
between personal sympathy with a
colleague I'd worked well with I liked
and uh systemic sympathy I think the
system is is uh needs a closer closer
attention than just accepting Don Robb's
work let me put another way you
concerned that if ministers and the
Prime Minister doesn't come out to kind
of stick up for the Civil Service the
Civil Service will be unfairly vilified
by all of this
that is a possibility because one aspect
is the Silence of civil servants that a
debate can rage about them without any
serving Civil Service participation so
that I think is an unfair debate and
that is another reason for me as a
retired civil servant to speak out
because I I work for the civil service
for 38 years the characterization given
by Mr Rob I think is flat wrong because
the Prime Minister fallen short in his
response
the Prime Minister when he became prime
minister
promised a government of Integrity
accountability and professionalism uh I
mean I think that the resignations that
we have seen so far are compatible with
that ambition but it's a it's an
ambition that has to be met has to be
fulfilled every day and every week in
politics so by actions but he's not
backing it up with words to back up the
interpreting professions of the Civil
server well we'll see I mean this is
still the first week